so Ken now we're just talking about this
past thing with Mark Wahlberg 1988
what's going 1988
well 1986 was the first one so what
happened so he posted about George Floyd
and this is his post right here the
Murdock George Floyd is heartbreaking we
must all work to fix the problem I'm
praying for all of us god bless okay and
then people place matter people recall
when he used to do racist things back
when he was younger and it's kind of
it's pretty bad in 1986 when he's 15
court documents state that Wahlberg was
among a group of white boys harassed a
group of black fourth graders in Boston
were on a field trip to Beach by chasing
him down the street throwing rocks on
racial slurs case 15km 1988 15 1988 a
separate more severe encourage when he
did time behind bars for being a
Vietnamese shopkeeper and was he 16 here
are 17 over case of beer the actor
served 45 days of a two-year sentence he
has since apologized what's the problem
here I mean it's young and made stupid
yeah horrible the states when he was he
said Woody something now and he was a
Boston kid okay and now no he's why was
he 50 now cool so you want so whatever
you did I'll see here's the problem
though this this comet which who gives a
flying [ __ ] about cops but I don't
really care who is it that it doesn't
make him any exception if you're racist
you're always going to be racist no wow
here's the problem Wow well there's the
problem why are we marching to change
everything there so do you think it
changed her mind why you March and for
him to want to erase it I do think it's
wrong Kristen Atwood you're a dumb-dumb
I was one of the victims at Wahlberg's
1986 attack attack get the [ __ ] out of
here
your thesis is that you're a [ __ ]
dummy but what they did so they want to
lose this critic of course there's no
apology what you did at 15 when you were
a minor before you could vote or
anything you should be punished for the
rest of your life Brandon why don't you
just kill him it's the same thing you
[ __ ] but these are morons these people
are so certainly there's learned there
literally ups up beside you learned from
Drew Brees so Drew Brees makes that
thing where he goes you know
disrespecting the flag you messed up
there and then he's like oh [ __ ] I
didn't realize it educate himself was
like I messed up their issues an apology
his teammates like right that's fine
even though everyone still wants to kill
Drew Brees
then Trump goes I actually I wish to
reason apologize then drew brees goes at
Trump like no no you're misinformed I
was misinformed you're misinformed so
now he's an app he's a much bigger
advocate for black lives matter if you
mean the enemy in glasses yeah because
he learned something and he got a
perspective minded he got a perspective
because you can change few [ __ ]
dummies but we shouldn't be talking
about morons like this because they're
so stupid they're so stupid and they're
said they don't like people and they
don't want change what they want they're
see people love having an enemy if you
take an enemy away from certain groups
and activists they don't have anything
to do they lose their job they need
racists they and if they can't find
racists they will make racist of people
that this is what happens if you if you
are an activist and that's your entire
identity and take a look at some of
these activists they're not stable
people once will not happen they're a
mess they never get laid I'm not saying
activists are all this way I'm saying
that when you see these people who are
just unforgiving they're not all there
these are these people are
psychologically very questionable and
they're cool and they're not good people
so so they're gonna find they their
whole identity is wrapped around this
fight take the fight away it's a big
problem it's exactly like in a
revolution when you have a militia and
they started what happens after every
revolution with the exception the
American Revolution they [ __ ] they
they they they break up into two
factions and they start fighting for
power exactly what what happened with
the foot bro put the foot baby birth no
my feet are pretty babies my feet tires
bro well no you wear a nine and a half
I wear ten and a half tiger worse than I
have I worked him really enough I work
10 hours I have Papa I worked in a knife
say it again baby bird you got to be
careful cuz I baby lose you and I feel
like I might go surf and turf I'll [ __ ]
you up Monday if you want [ __ ] up
Monday no it's not [ __ ] up Monday it's
slap handle burger on Monday it's
counter it's counter you've choked the
bird out Monday how are you Monday [ __ ]
face choke the old bird watch you took
watch your tone for real hey I'm gonna
lock your house son in Phoenix you
locked me out of the house and I won't
weaker racist
sorry right if you love lose all my job
I have to go there you caught me a
racial slur oh yeah I'm gonna lock you
out of house see you fry in the Sun baby
bird racist what else you got
I think it's also important to note that
back in 2016 this was actually something
that resurfaced for Mark Wahlberg as
well because he was trying to become an
honorary cop or something and he needed
a pardon for the attack against the
venom a shop owner and they actually
tracked down the owner and asked him
about the situation the owner said that
there were a couple things that were
wrong in the media people said that Mark
Wahlberg blinded him in one eye during
the attack heard that but it actually
isn't true he was blinded when he still
lived in Vietnam when he was serving in
the Army yeah and he also says that Mark
Wahlberg at the time was a young kid nut
he personally forgives him he's like we
all deserve that's all that matters that
guy was involved directly with the
situation yeah
so if he and also Mark Wahlberg made
invincible so it's chill it's like
George Floyd's brother who said I'm
sorry yeah George brother said I'm the
one who's dealing with this if I'm not
doing violent [ __ ] what are you all
doing any screaming educate yourself
mmm-hmm so Rodney King did that same
thing cinema yeah he well on the news
that's right but that was the beginning
[Music]
right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue Oh what's gonna happen what are
you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]